Alright guys, so here is an example number two for the Holy Grail strategy, I'm looking
at your AUD on the weekly timeframe, so for this example, we're going to go from weekly
to 4 over to 15 minutes, okay?
So right away, you can see that we have taken out the weekly external liquidity, which was
this high over here, now where is the Fair Valley Gap?
This tiny little Fair Valley Gap is going to be a drawn liquidity, which is just right
here, there's no further gap here, so that is going to be a draw.
Let's go to the 4 over timeframe now, and let's see what has happened.
So we took out the liquidity here, right, over here, then we have a push up, and going
into this level, what you can see is that we have a shift in the market structure right
here, right?
So now, we want to mark out the PD area in the discount, sorry, in the premium.
Once we have this, we want to look for the premium Fair Valley Gap or auto vlog, so
right here, we also have a tiny little Fair Valley Gap, right?
So price has now tapped into this level, so let's go here.
Now once that happens, we want to mark out this range low to this range high, this move,
right?
This was the last move to the downside before price started moving up to the PD area.
So now going to the 15 minute timeframe, what we need to do is to identify the consolidation
phase, right?
So over here, we have this very clean consolidation, and that is what you want to look for in most
cases, okay?
Right there, we have a clean cut consolidation, then we have another consolidation phase here,
then we have another consolidation or recommendation phase, whatever you want to call it, right?
And let me mark this out.
So now what we are simply waiting for is a shift in the market structure, and it happens
right away.
So remember when I said that Wix matter for this strategy, right?
We have a Wix, so that is giving us a sign that, okay, we have a break in structure now.
So now, where do we have the extreme Fair Valley Gap here?
We have the Fair Valley Gap just around here, right?
So playing this through.
Now what do we have?
We have a shift in the market structure, then we have a break of structure.
So remember that second distribution entry, we are looking for that at the moment, okay?
So let's see.
So now we have a purge on this high over here.
We have also mitigated this Fair Valley Gap, let me mark this out.
This Fair Valley Gap here.
So now what we want to wait for is a double break of structure, and there we have our
double break of structure, we have a lower low, lower high, lower low, right there.
We didn't take this because we have lower low, lower high, lower low, but then there
was no Fair Valley Gap, unmitigated Fair Valley Gap here.
So now what we did, we considered this whole move as a lower low, lower high, lower low.
So now we have this Fair Valley Gap, and as you can see, we could have maybe gotten
a entry of this breaker block just here, or we could have used the 50% of the Fair Valley
Gap because it is way too big.
So using the 0.5 level, right?
This would have been your second distribution entry, right there.
Stop goes just around here, and this is our drawn liquidity.
So let's see how this plays out.
All right.
So as you can see, the take profit was hit.
Another thing is, unlike my other basic strategies, you have to look for these setups, right?
So you will not always get the tap on the Extreme Fair Valley Gap.
You have to look for those things that I've taught you in this whole update, okay?
You have to look for second distribution entry.
If you get that setup, that is absolutely beautiful, okay?
And you can see that we have a break of structure right here, sorry, a change of, sorry, we
have a market structure shift here, then we have a break of structure, right?
And then we have a purge or ABCD, right?
That's what I call it.
And then what you wait for is a double break of structure, right?
So now, if you really think about it here, we also had a lower low, lower high and lower
low here.
So you could have actually taken your entry from this Fair Valley Gap here as well from
the 50% put your stop right above this high and you could have targeted this level, right?
No problem, but in most cases, you can consider this as a lower low, lower high, lower low
as well, right?
There's no problem with that.
You have a small second distribution entry here as well, but then you have a larger like
a pullback and that is absolutely fine, okay?
If you have taken your entry from there, that is also good because you are following the
rules here, right?
We literally had our entry here.
That is a valid entry.
We have a lower low, lower high, lower low.
And that is the entry from the 50% or from this autoblock right there.
So yeah, you could have taken your entry here as well because remember, our bias was set,
right?
Our take profit was said, we have identified the consolidation.
So this should have worked on every single PD area is going to be respected.
So right here, this Fair Valley Gap was respected, right?
In the premium, right here.
What do we have?
We have a break of structure.
This Fair Valley Gap was respected.
Then we have another break of structure.
What do we have?
Nothing to be, nothing here, actually a, this candle right here.
We have another break of structure, right?
Price respects this autoblock.
And we keep going down, then we have the continuation purge or the A, B, A, B, C actually here.
And then boom, to the take profit level.
So that's how you frame your trades.
If you can learn to do this, guys, like it will require some practicing because, you
know, normally you would be waiting for price to tap into your Fair Valley Gap here, right?
But then as I told you, the second distribution entry, you have to keep that in mind.
You mitigate it only this Fair Valley Gap and then the setup provided us the, the second
distribution entry.
We could have got in here or considered this whole move as a lower low, lower high and
lower low and entry of the 50% level.
Our bias was strong, so we targeted this level.
So let's move on to the next example now.